puis toujours voulu être papa
j'ai juste mis 46 ans à réaliser mon
rêve c'est qu'à mettre de la terre
dessus vous devriez mettre au moins un
truc genre antibactérien pour éviter une
infection c'est un vrai médecin ou tu as
eu un diplôme sur Internet c'est un truc
que tout le monde sait il faut que la
blessure reste propre écoute moi
j'essaie d'en faire un mec pas une
tu devrais essayer de les poster sur
Twitter le héros de ta vie
tu as pu écouter le nouveau morceau que
les Baby a posté allez vas-y chez moi un
petit bœuf
ça va
les gars mettez-les en veilleuse faut
impressionner notre homme le changement
entre renouvelle plus vite que quand
vous étiez plus jeune aujourd'hui nous
allons vendre des vêtements du 21e
siècle non genre et neutre carbone j'ai
absolument rien compris il faut que tu
vois quelqu'un pour parler de ta colère
vous étiez en retard on accepte pas les
excuses
règlement pourri espèce de sang
tu penses que ta génération est plus
évoluée ouais bien sûr ça marche pas
appuie sur le truc dépêche-toi
mon téléphone tu te fous de moi
j'ai pas fait pour cette vie là
je freine n'importe quoi pour mon gamin
[Musique]
que j'étais à ton âge Julio Iglesias est
venu me voir à l'aéroport parce qu'il
croyait que j'étais son fils Enrique
ouais voilà la de Fight que je
dégagé c'est ridicule
[Musique]
c'est moi qui était ridicule
est-ce qu'il y a une raison pour que ce
soit toujours deux hommes blancs qui
dominent la discussion dans cette pièce
il est pas blanc lui un peu confus